Україна може стати стартап-нацією
вважає прем’єр-міністр Володимир Гройсман
Він переконаний - досягти цього цілком реально
Жодного урядового фонду підтримки стартапів в Україні натепер не існує
Як розповіли DW у міністерстві економічного розвитку та торгівлі
створення такого фонду - лише у планах
Проте його поява найближчим часом - під питанням
адже грошей на це в держбюджеті, принаймні на наступний рік, не передбачено
Тим часом найближчі сусіди України, зокрема, Росія
вкладають в стартапи сотні тисяч євро
Натомість українські стартапи більше підтримують з-за кордону
Польщі, США, Ізраїлю, Німеччини - через посольства або програми підтримки
Скільки саме в Україні стартапів
не беруться порахувати ані оглядачі ринку, ані його учасники
Немає такої статистики і в Мінекономіки
Тож, яке місце у світі посідає Україна
за розвитком стартапів, сказати складно
Але, приміром, у рейтингу мегаполісів
з найкращими умовами для розвитку стартапів
Global Startup Ecosystem Ranking
жодного українського міста немає
Більшість позицій там - за США та Китаєм
Підтримати українських бізнесменів-початківців
могли б так звані стартап-акселератори
тобто компанії, які інвестують у стартапи і допомагають їхньому розвитку
Але натепер в Україні, за даними оглядачів
є лише кілька таких компаній
Вони активно відкривалися 6-7 років тому
а потім так само активно закрилися
За останні кілька років в Україні
за даними одного з найбільших стартап-акселераторів GrowthUp
з’явилися від 300 до 600 молодих компаній
Однак, як констатують оглядачі
більшість успішних українських стартапів орієнтуються
на європейський та американський ринки, і тому реєструють свої компанії там
Заснувати ж в Україні стартап новачкам на ринку нескладно лише в теорії
Натомість на практиці підприємці стикаються з численними складнощами
Від отримання грошей за відсутності в Україні системи Пейпал
та проблем на митниці до незахищеності бізнесу
Українці справді мають неабиякий потенціал
багато українських проектів стали всесвітньо відомими
Але усі вони працюють і фінансуються переважно з-за кордону
Жодного урядового фонду підтримки стартапів в Україні немає
а Кабмін навіть не веде статистику кількості молодих компаній
Тому спрогнозувати
коли і чи стане взагалі Україна
нацією стартапів, важко